ونحييكم الى تفاصيل ملفنا الاول بين سعودي
ايراني مشترك يعد استكمالا لخطوات البلدين
نحو مزيدا من التقارب وعوده العلاقات عوده
ينتظر ان يكون لها تاثير ايجابي على
المنطقه عموما هذا البيان جاء قبل لقاء
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان بوزير خارجيه ايران امير عبد
اللهيان في العاصمه الصينيه
اهم ما تم التوصل اليه هو بدء الترتيب
لاعاده فتح السفرات والقنصليات بالاضافه
الى استئناف الرحلات الجويه وتسهيل منح
تاشيرات نص البيان ايضا او نص على تفعيل
اتفاقيه التعاون الامنيه الموقعه عام 2021
ماده نتابع اهم ماجه فيها
اتفاقيه التعاون الامني بين الرياض وطهران
تم توقيعها عام 2001 تضمنت التعاون في
مجال التدريب الامني وتبادل الخبرات
والمعلومات منع الهجره غير المشروعه وفرض
ضوابط الحدود والمياه الاقليميه التعاون
في مجال الانقاذ البحري والتسلل غير
المشروع التنسيق والتعاون في مجال مكافحه
الارهاب والمخدرات وغسيل الاموال تسهيلات
اكبر للحجاج والمعتمرين الايرانيين وسماح
السلطات الايرانيه بفتح ابوابها امام
السعوديين دون الحاجه الى الحصول على
تاشيره دخول مكافحه الاتجار غير المشروع
بالمخدرات وتطوير التعاون الثنائي لمنع
الجريمه المنظمه انشاء منتدى امني للحوار
الاستراتيجي بين الجانبين لمواجهه اقطار
الجريمه المنظمه والارهاب التعاون في
مراقبه الحدود والمياه الاقليميه بين
البلدين لمنع التهريب والاخلال الامني
البيان السعوديه والايراني والمشترك وصادر
عن وزراء خارجيه البلدين تضمن ايضا اعاده
تفعيل اتفاقيه التعاون الموقعه عام
1998 والتي تتضمن مقدمه وثمانيه مواد
متابعه كذلك
اتفاقيه التعاون العام بين السعوديه
وايران تم توقيعها عام
1998 اهم ما جاء فيها التعاون في المجالات
الاقتصاديه والتجاريه والاستثماريه
والعلميه والتقنيه والثقافيه والرياضيه
تشجيع وتسهيل الاستثمارات المشتركه وتبادل
زيارات الوفود التجاريه امكانيه توقيع
الجانبين اتفاقيات اخرى يجدانها مناسبه في
اي من هذه المجالات تشكيل لجنه اقتصاديه
مشتركه على المستوى الوزاري
نناقش هذا الملف مع ضيوفنا من الرياض جسر
الجسر الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بك ومن لندن بعد
قليل ينضم لنا المفروض عارف نصر الباحث في
الشان الايراني اهلا بكم ضيوفي سابدا معك
استاذ جاسر لنحاول فهم هذه المرحله من
التقارب الايراني السعودي بمعنى انه اذا
عدنا للترتيب التسلسلي يوم 10 مارس كان
هناك اتفاق موافقه اليوم هناك اعلان عن
اتفاق تفعيل في غضون هذا الشهر الماضي
كانت هناك ثلاثه صالات هاتفيه بين وزري
الخارجيه والمفروض بانه في خلال شهر قادم
سيتم الانتهاء من اجراءات تفعيل ما اتفق
عليه كيف تعلق على مسار التعامل بين
الطرفين حتى هذه اللحظه
مساء الخير
طبعا المؤشرات الاولى توحد بان هناك يعني
تسارع في العمليه نعتبر مثل هذا الاتفاقات
بين السعوديه وايران مثل سباق التتابع
مراحل يجب ان تتحقق قد تتعثر مرحله في
مرحله لكن في المهم النتيجه النهائيه ما
يحصل اليوم هو عمليه تسريع واضحه هناك
لحاح ايراني على العوده وهناك اعتقد ايضا
يعني قابليه قابليه سعوديه لكن ضمن يعني
التحقق من المتطلبات والاشتراطات المتفق
عليها ولعل ذلك انه اختارت المملكه بكين
يعني لنشهد على فكره في جانب مهم انه في
اثنان لقال الوزيرين
الهيان وزير الخارجيه الايراني قال ان
الرحله شاقه الى بكينو قالوا الامير فيصل
تراها من الرياض من طهران للرياض ساعتين
بمعنى انه اختيار بكين هو اختيار سعودي
لاعاده يعني
فرض وجود الطرف الصيني الضامن في هذه
المعادله على التحقيق للتسريع يعني لا
تريد المملكه ان هناك مخاطرات لا تريد
المملكه ان تكون هناك هي فقط يعني مرحله
مرحليه تريد ان ترسخ هذا الاتفاق والتعاون
ونتخذ اوطر واضحه وصريحه وان يتم بناء على
خطوات عمليه تعزز هذا التعاون بين البلدين
المؤشرات نعم تقول لكن نلاحظ حتى البيان
ترى البيان السعودي ايضا البيان المصغر من
هناك تطلع سعودي الرغبه في التنسيق الحث
على يعني هناك متطلبات تامل انها تتحقق
ولذلك يعني هناك حماس يحدث هذا الاتفاق
ويتحقق وتمضي المسارات بشكل كامل لكن ايضا
هناك الحرص الحرص نعم الحرص على تحقيق
المتطلبات التي التي اقرت في اتفاق بكين
وهي طبعا نعلم انها كلها تفاصيل غير معلنه
اضافه لذلك
تضمن ايضا تفاصيل البيان السعودي الايراني
هذا اعلان عما تم ولكنه ليس ما تم ما تم
هناك تفاصيل كثيره اكيد نقشت وتحدثت
وحضرها الطرف الصيني واعلنت مرحله تشجع او
تؤيد تق انه ممكن احنا نتطور بشكل اسرع
ونحقق نتائج افضل في المرحله المقبله لانه
اذا اتفق الطرفان فعلا على انه تحقيق
الاستقرار في المنطقه وعدم التدخل في شؤون
البلدان الاخرى بالتالي قامت ايران بهذا
الدور فنحن سنصل الى مرحله ايجابيه ستسرع
ليس فقط يعني قد لا يكون انتظار الشرايين
ممكن تتخذ خطوات اذا كانت ايران قدمت فعلا
متطلبات بشكل اسرع تحقيق السلام في
المنطقه يمر باتفاقتين في الواقع اتفاقيه
امنيه كانت ابرمت في 2001 وهذه الاتفاقيه
هي التيسه تمهد الطريق الاتفاقيه ثانيه
وهي اتفاقيه عامه تشمل التجاره والصناعه
والثقافه الى اخره والتي اتفق عليها سنه
98 وهنا سؤال استاذ عارف الاتفاقيه
الامنيه الى اي مدى هناك تجاوب ايراني
وقدره ايرانيه على
تحقيقها والالتزام بها خاصه
تحيه طيبه لك
العربيه الكرام وكذلك ضيفكم الكريم
باحتقادي للاجابه على هذا السؤال يجب ان
نعرف طبيعه السياسه الخارجيه الايرانيه
السياسه التي تنقسم الى ثابت ومتحول عاده
عندما كانت السياسه الداخليه الايرانيه
تنقسم الى اصلاحه واصولين عمليا كان هنالك
شريك الى الجانب السعودي وكذلك الدول
منطقه الخليج عندما خرجوا
الاصلاحيين من المشهد السياسي فعمليا
هنالك لا يوجد شريك لذلك تم العوده الى
هذه الاتفاقيات لكن هذه المره بقوه اكبر
لان من اعطى الضوء الاخضر الى هذه
الاتفاقيه هو المرشد نفسه الجانب الثابت
بالسياسه الخارجيه لذلك انا اعتقد ان
العوده هي ناتجه من ان الجانب او الحكومه
الحاليه ليست لديها صلاحيات كافيه
وبالتالي نحتفظ هذا الامر يحسب الى الجانب
السعودي بانه اختار بعنايه كيف ان يعيد
العلاقات مع الجانب
الايراني اعتقد
لافهم من حضرتك هذه النقطه لما تقول بانه
هذه الاتفاقيه او على الاقل البدء
بالاتفاق على تنفيذ هذه النقاط من اشرف
على ذلك هو المرشد الايراني هو ان الحكومه
لا يمكنها التدخل في مجريات او في تفاصيل
هكذا تنفيذ ما الذي تقصده هل هذه النقطه
تعد ايجابيه او سلبيه لبقيه المسار
هذه الامر تحسب الى الجانب السعودي بانه
اختار ان يكون الضامن الداخلي لتفعيل هذه
الاتفاقيات الان المرشد الايراني لان
حكومه رئيسي لا حول لها ولا قوه لتفعيل
هذه الاتفاقيات المهمه خاصه انها تتضمن
قضايا حساسه منها حتى تبادل السجناء ونحن
نعلم
الكثير من المطلوبين الى الجهات الامنيه
موجودين على الاراضي الايرانيه والكثير
بما فيهم اعظامنا القاعده وغيرها وكذلك
الكثير من الملفات التي بامكانها ان تكون
ربما عمليه اعاده ثقه بين الطرفين لذلك
انا اعتقد بانها ايجابيه هذه هذه الشاكله
من الاتفاق او تفعيل الاتفاق الى الجانب
السعودي اكثر من نقطه
استاذ جاسر منذ شهر كنا نتحدث عن اتفاق
موافقه على تفعيل اتفاقيه امنيه كان اتفق
عليها الجانبان سنه 2001 اليوم بدنا نتحدث
على اتفاق لتفعيل هذه الاتفاقيه الامنيه
تفعيل هذه الاتفاقيه الامنيه سيقول البعض
يرتبط بامرين الحرف في اليمن والحرس
الثوري ايهما اسهل او على الاقل اولويه
للجانبين بحسب رايك
طبعا الحرصنه اعتقد انه المعنيه اساسا
بتفعيل الاتفاقيه الامنيه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه لان التهديد ياتي او كنا ياتي من
الجانب الايراني الملفات كلهم يعني هناك
يعني ثلاثه مهمه في الاتفاقيه مكافحه
الارهاب غسيل الاموال والمخدرات مكافحه
الارهاب هذه تقضيه طبعا بالدعم الحوثي هو
دعم للارهاب ليس فقط يعني نشاط وبالتالي
مواجهه هذا التحدي هذه نقطه محوريه
واساسيه ومن دونها لن يكون هناك تحرك لا
اتوقع ان بكره تنشا علاقات بين السعوديه
وايران وفي نفس الوقت ترسل للحوث صواريخ
يهاجم المملكه هذا يعني ندخل احنا في
مرحله بثيه بهذه نقطه مهمه ايضا التدريب
وايواء مثل مذكرة مين عارف الكوادر
الارهابيه المهدده المنطقه ورعايتها
والتحريض كل هذه الجوانب يعني انا اعتقد
حينما اجتمع الجانبان خاصه في بكير في
المره الاولى مساعد العيبان مع شبخاني كان
اعتقد كان هناك ملفات تحمل تحمل هذه
الشواهد والاختراقات والتجاوزات
والتهديدات ليس كلاما يعني عاما لا نتكلم
على تفاصيل نقشه نقطه نقطه وربما اسم اسم
وربما حاله حاله للوصوله الاتفاق وبالتالي
الاقرار بان هذه المشاكل ستعالج وتتخذ
الخطوات اعاده تفعيل اليوم نحن نتكلم الان
عن المستوى السياسي دخول وزيري الخارجيه
رفع المستوى الى المستوى السياسي وبالتالي
الاطار الاشمل العام لكن يبقى المحتوى
الاساسي الذي هو التهديدات الامنيه
والعسكريه التي تهدد استقرار المنطقه اذا
اولا تهديد استقرار المملكه هذا النقطه
الاساسيه يجب ان يتم حسمها خطوه اولى بدون
اي نقاش فيما يتصل في اليمن مما يتصل كادر
الارهابيه جميعا وهي نشاطات اخرى تهدد امن
المملكه هذه جبن تقفل النكته الاخرى في
تفعيل التعاون الامني زياده درجه التنسيق
بين الطرفين على المستجدات والتعاون معها
والنقطه الثالثه تاتي اللي مساله
الميليشيات وما يتصل فيها في تهديد
استقرار المنطقه العربيه اذا احنا نقول
واضح انه تم هناك واضح هناك يعني لنقل
او اندفاع ايراني كامل ايران تريد ان
تتنفس وهذه من الاتفاقيه وهذا الاتفاق بين
الطرفين هو يعطي ايران نافذه من الاسترخاء
والامل انها تتجاوز ازماتها المختلفه
والمتعدده وبالتالي المملكه ترحب بهذا
السياق ولكن ماذا سيحدث على الارض مهم جدا
ماذا سيحدث على الارض المتفائلون ولكن
بحذر قائمين على القواعد اذا كله ورقه
تقدم اليوم او كل خطوه تتخذ هي ستكون
علامه وبرهان على تسريع بالمقابل كل هذه
التفاصيل لن تعلن لن يعلن في يوم انه كذا
طبعا ايران لن تعلن انها اوقف الدعم
الحوثي وهي تزعم لا علاقه له لكن اعتقد
هذه في الغرف الداخليه في الغرف المغلقه
سيتم مناقشه الملف عمليا واطفائه بدون ان
يكون هناك اعلانات صحيح يكون هناك ارتياح
سعودي تتسرع الخطوه الاخرى ولكن يبقى سؤال
من هي ايران التي نتحدث عنها ايران المرشد
ايران الحكومه او ايران الحرس الثوري
استاذ عارف لتحقيق اسلاف في المنطقه يقول
البعض يجب ان ندخل من بوابه انهاء الحرب
في اليمن هل تعتقد بان الحرس الثوري قد
يلتزم بما اتفق عليه او ان هناك مخاوف من
امكانيه التمرد
الواقع بان فيما يتعلق بهذا الاتفاق انا
اعتقد ما دام نحن شهدنا ثلاثه مسارات الى
هذا الاتفاق او على الاقل تفعيل هذا
الاتفاق
عندما كانت بالمرحله امنيه لذلك الهواجس
امنيه اللقاءات امنيه لا ضمان بان لا يكون
هناك تمرد من قبل
الحرس الثوره او فيلق القدس او الميليشيات
التابعه لكنما شاهدنا بالنقطه الثانيه
عندما التقى الجانب السعودي مع الايراني
في مكان مع شمخان انا اعتقد بان هذا الامر
كان نصف امني ونصف الدبلوماسي انتقاله
الان مع زياره ربما الجانبين وزير
الخارجيه السعودي والجانب الايراني هو
يشير بانه هنالك انتقال الملف الى مرحله
امنيه ما دام ان هنالك انتقال الى مرحله
دبلوماسيه فهذا يشير بان هنالك تطمينات
للطرفين لكنما
في عنا هذا المسار لن يبدا من القضايا
الامنيه بل يبدا من القضايا التجاريه
القضايا ربما الاقتصاديه وعوده العلاقات
والانصليات والسيارات لكنما
تحقيق الجوانب الامنيه والهواجس الامنيه
يحتاج الى وقت اكبر
للتحقق من تفاصيل وهذه نقطه مهمه في
الواقع حتى ان هذا البيان فهم منه البعض
استاذ جاسر بان تبادل او تعاون التجاري هو
الذي قد يمهد الطريق امام تحقيق الامن
وامام تفعيل التعاون الامني بمعنى انه
عوده السفارات عوده القنصليات فتح الباب
للتاشيرات تسهيل دخول القطاع الخاص للبدء
بمحاوله زرع استثمارات حقيقيه بين
السعوديه وايران الى اي مدى ايران تحرص
على انجاح هذه الخطوه وهذه المرحله
انا اعتقد اولا حتى لو تم فتح السفرات
اليس بالضروره ان نصل الى التوقع المامول
من طبيعه العلاقه قد تتعثر في مرحله اخرى
قد تتغير الاصوات نحن نتكلم على وضع داخل
ايران ملامحه غير واضحه بمعنى مثلا اذا
كان خامني هو المشرف على هذا والداعم لو
رحل ماذا سيكون فهذه اشكالات اخرى
مستقبليه مفتوحه الحاله الوحيده التي تؤكد
نجاح هذا الاتفاق ووصوله هو بدء تدفق
الاستثمارات السعوديه الى ايران وبناء
الشراكات التجاريه
الاقتصاد لا ينمو الا في بيئه مستقره
وامنه لا ينجح مهما تطورنا تبادل السفراء
تاشيرات عمره قد يعني يبقى الوضع الى حد
ما قلق اذا لم تكن في اللحظه التي يبدا
التدفق الاستمارات والشراكات الاقتصاديه
والتعاون التجاري بين البلدين هنا نقول
انه المساله فعلا البلدان اتفق تماما
ازيلت كل الشوائب يتطلعان الى مستقبل
مشترك يطلعن للتعاون والتعزيز وبالتالي
تنميه الاقتصادي في الحاله الاولى على ما
يصلح هذه النقطه صحيح ولكن استاذ جاسر
اعذرني على المقاطعه حضرتك تقول وهذا مبدا
حقيقه بان الاستثمار لا يمكن ان يحدث
وينجح الا في باسالمه ولكن هل يمكن ان
نشهد استثناءات خاصه وان الحاله السعوديه
الايرانيه هي استثناء وهناك يعني تطورات
شهدناها وعشناها ومتغيرات عديده هل يمكن
ان تسبق الاستثمارات السلام بمعنى ان تدفع
الاستثمارات بامر واقع يهدا من خلاله
الاطراف او تهدا الاطراف ويحل السلام في
مرحله مقبله او مرحله تاليه
يكون خاص بافراد وبمجموعات وبمؤسسات
ستنتقل لتبدا بالعمل نتحدث على المجموعات
الدبلوماسيه نتحدث على القطاع الخاص نتحدث
على من سيذهب من المستثمرين للبدء بالعمل
الى اي مدى ايران قادره فعلا على تامينهم
لانه الشارع الايراني والمجموعات
الايرانيه مختلفا تحدث عن الحدث الثوري
ولكن نتحدث كذلك عن مجموعه اخرى هل يمكن
لايران انت في بوعودها فيما يخص هذه
الجزئيه على الاقل
يعني اعتقد للاجابه على هذا السؤال يجب ان
نفهم بان هنالك اتجاهين الاتجاه الاول هو
اتجاه السعوديه الذي لديه رؤيه 2030
وبالتالي يحاول تصوير المشاكل الاتجاه
الثاني الايراني هو ربما يرى بان لتحقيق
المشاكل الاخرى سيما المشاكل المتعلقه
بالملف النووي وكذلك الكثير من المشاكل
سيما حتى المشاكل الداخليه يجب ان تتوجه
الى الشرق ربما
التوجهين يتغيان بنقطه واحده وهي ان
الجانب السعودي الى جانب الجانب الايراني
يلتقيان بان يرون بان الاحاديه القطبيه
التي موجوده في العلاقات الدوليه لم تعد
تجدي الى تحقيق هذه المكاسب الى الطرفين
لذلك ربما ستارو الجانب الصيني لذلك انا
اعتقد بان الدوله هو الذي ممكن ان ان
ربما يمهد الى
الثقه المتبادله وكذلك هذه البيئه التي
تتيح الاستثمار
بين البلدين سنبقى في متابعه كل هذا
ينتظرنا شهر المفيد هم تحدثوا ببيانهم
الاول في العشره من مارس عن 60 يوم
ينتظرنا شهر تقريبا لفهم ملامح تفعيل كل
هذه النقاط اود شكرا لكم باننا سنبقى في
متابعه لكل هذه التفاصيل من الرياض جسر
الجسر الكاتب الصحفي شكرا لك ومن لندن عرف
ناصر بحفر شان الايراني شكرا لكم